dude
all hail selena gomez the queen of tic
tac we hope everybody enjoys it on
tuesday the 29 year old actress posted a
clip to tick tock alongside the caption
quote every day with all of my friends
dude
why
yeah and what has fans totally shook is
that that isn't selena talking she's
lip-syncing to the sound from this
original video
dude
[Laughter]
pretty impressive right it was so much
fun well her acting chops aren't the
only thing that has fans talking in the
clip selena is also rocking a new short
sleek blunt bob hairstyle the only
murderers in the building star debuted
the look earlier in the day with this
tick tock announcing she would be
hosting a live stream to chat with fans
join me for a watch party of the final
episode where i will also be answering
some of your questions i think we should
just hit him with the chart good
excellent so i'll take the lead on this
excuse me yeah and that new do is giving
fans major throwback wizards of waverly
place vibes
yes
so then i guess this party's for me too
and it's no surprise selena has quickly
become a fan favorite on tic tac she
recently proved she's hashtag relatable
with this post napping on the couch
which she captioned quote i just don't
want to work today but i promise i'm
making my best album yet
so what are you doing
right now
she also shared this clip from the
trailer of the upcoming season three of
selina and chef
i think you're cute too oh wait what is
happening cause you're talking to me or
you
me yep that's selena getting flirty with
chef kwame on wachi we're getting
flustered on me now we're here to cook
that's our cooking show folks the 29
year old singer is back for more fun in
the kitchen but this time she's blonde
and seemingly cooking her best creations
to date
this would not have happened season one
this is my favorite meal i've ever made
hell yeah i'm excited for what's coming
and while the season one finale of only
murders in the building just aired fans
are already itching for season two now
she's the third amigo i'm officially the
third amiga amigo i should say e.t
recently sat down with the cast and
selena gushed over working with acting
legends steve martin and martin short i
could barely keep a straight face just
hanging out with them it was so
wonderful and i learned so much being
around them they're legends in their own
right but they've you know they're good
people humble funny kind and
professional and it was just the best
you